Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 52. Ausgabe von Raumzeit, wo wir uns heute mal einem Himmelskörper nähern wollen, den wir bisher ganz sträflich ausgelassen haben. Und zwar war hier viel die Rede von Planeten und natürlich auch der Erde im besonderen im letzten Jahr und ja, was so ein bisschen aus dem Blickfeld geraten ist, ist die Sonne. Und ja, dann wollen wir sie also genau deswegen auch mal ins Blickfeld schieben und das anlässlich einer Mission, die die ESA plant, in den nächsten Jahren zu starten zur Sonne. Gemeint ist die Mission Solar Orbiter. Und um darüber zu reden, da muss man natürlich zur ESA fahren, konkret nach Darmstadt zum ESORG, zum Europäischen Raumfeldkontrollzentrum. Und da sind wir jetzt auch und ich spreche heute mit Paolo. Paolo Ferri, hallo, willkommen bei Raumzeit. Ja, du bist hier auch schon eine Weile dabei. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Eine Langeweile. 28 Jahre, aber nicht langeweilig. Ohne Langeweile.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass hier keine Langeweile aufkommt. Was hat dich denn hierher geführt zu dem Thema? Ist du auch so ein Mondlande-Opfer?
Ja, natürlich. Ich bin Kind der 60er-Jahre, Ende 59 geboren und wie alle Kinder, die sowas in ihrem neunten oder zehnten Lebensjahr erlebt haben, war ich so enthousiastisch, ich wollte natürlich Astronaut werden. Später habe ich immer dieses Ziel im Blick gehalten, habe ich Physik studiert und dann quasi per Zufall gab es hier eine Möglichkeit als Wissenschaftler mitzuarbeiten, eine sehr alte Mission, jetzt ein Röntgenstrahl-Teleskop, Exosatistas in den 80er Jahren, also 1984 bin ich hierher gekommen, frisch aus der Uni und dann sehr schnell zu Mission Operations gewechselt und dann immer hier geblieben.
Also Mission Operations hier der Überblick über und die Steuerung vor allem von den ganzen Missionen, die eben aktiv betrieben werden, aber man ist ja da auch schon früh eingebunden, auch bevor die Raumfahrzeuge das All betreten, dass man sich dann schon vorher drum kümmern muss.
Ja, also die Vorbereitung einer Mission fängt schon an viele Jahre vor dem Start. Man muss studieren, zum Beispiel die Umlaufbahnen und auch verschiedene Möglichkeiten, die man mit den Satelliten hat, mit den Raketen, wohin kann man kommen, wie stark die Rakete, wie schwer der Satellit und so weiter. Besonders bei interplanetaren Missionen wie Solar Orbiter, also Missionen, die weg von der Erde fliegen, ist diese Phase sehr kompliziert. Die Umlaufbahn ist sehr kompliziert, muss man viel berechnen. Also das startet schon, es kann sogar zehn Jahre vor dem Start sein. Bei Solar Orbiter war das ein bisschen kürzer. Jetzt sind wir schon in einer heißen Phase angekommen. Die Sonde wird bald gebaut, die sind in der Entwicklungsphase jetzt. Und wir fangen an jetzt unsere Bodensysteme zu spezifizieren und später dann Ende des Jahres zu implementieren.
Bevor wir auf die Mission selber kommen, wollte ich noch mal ein bisschen weiter ausholen, noch mal nachfragen. Also zunächst einmal Missionsplanung und Operations, das hängt ja eng zusammen. Das hatten wir ja auch schon ausführlich mal besprochen im Detail. Schon in der zweiten Ausgabe mit Markus Landgraf eine Ausgabe und konkret dann zu Operations mit Michel Dini, beide hier auch aus Darmstadt von der ESA. Ich fange noch mal kurz zurück auf diese Mondlandung, weil du ja auch so diese lange Perspektive hast. Es ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen schwierig, sich das heutzutage noch vorzustellen, mit dieser Selbstverständlichkeit, die die Raumfahrt mittlerweile hat. Satellitenbilder sieht man tagtäglich. Das ist alles eine Normalität geworden. Das war natürlich vor 40, 50 Jahren noch eine ganz andere Nummer. Wie hast du das erlebt? Also was hat das bewirkt? Und zwar jetzt nicht nur in dir, sondern vielleicht auch so um dich herum.
Ja, also zuerst Raumfahrt sieht so vielleicht von außen aus als Normalität geworden, ist es nicht. Es gibt bestimmte Bereiche, die einigermaßen serienmäßig jetzt bearbeitet werden. Sagen wir zum Beispiel Fernmeldesatelliten, sogar Erdbeobachtungssatelliten heutzutage. Es sind Satelliten, die ungefähr alle gleich sind oder die gleiche Zwecke haben. Da kann man das natürlich nicht mit Flugzeugen vergleichen. Aber eine bestimmte Serienmäßigkeit ist eingetroffen. Bei wissenschaftlichen Satelliten oder bemannten Missionen ist diese Pionierszeit noch nicht vorbei. Ich habe das erlebt, als ich hierher kam. Es war schon 15 Jahre nach der Mondlandung, als ich hierher kam. Mein erster Eindruck war, wenn man bei den Operationen alles miterlebt, ist, wie viele Details muss man einkalkulieren, muss man vorher planen, um etwas im Weltraum zu erreichen, ohne dass Katastrophen passieren. Mein erster Eindruck war unglaublich, wie es sein konnte, dass sie zum Mond vor 15 Jahren gelandet sind. Man arbeitet hier mit einer enormen Präzision, man muss alles einkalkulieren, einplanen, man muss zwei Fehler vorher denken, muss sich zwei Fehler überleben, sonst ist meine Mission kaputt. Auch Kleinigkeiten, die schief gehen könnten. Die Raumfahrt ist immer noch das. Eine Kleinigkeit und die Rakete explodieren. Die Lageregelung funktioniert nicht mehr. Ich verliere die Kontrolle, ich verliere das Signal. Unser Alptraum hier im Kontrollzentrum ist, das Signal zu verlieren. Kleinigkeiten können das verursachen. Man muss immer vorbereitet sein.
Man merkt ja auch, es passiert auch noch. Gerade in den letzten Jahren gab es wieder einige schmerzliche Verluste. Besonders die Russen waren jetzt von gleich mehreren Schicksalsschlägen betroffen. Absolut. Wobei bei der ESA lief es eigentlich ganz gut zuletzt.
Ja, unsere Erfahrung hat uns viel unterrichtet. Wir haben viel gelernt, dass man einige Regeln folgen muss. Also sehr strikt folgen muss, in dem Fall von dieser Mission Phobos Grund von den Russen, die am Start praktisch fehlgeschlagen ist. Da waren viele Sachen zusammengekommen, eine lange Zeit ohne Kontakt mit dem Boden geplant. Und ein Fehler, das während dieser Blackout-Phase passiert ist. Weniger Redundanz, also viele Grundregeln, die ein bisschen leichtsinnig nicht respektiert wurden. Und schon wird es bestraft. Und dann wird es bestraft. Also wie gesagt, unser Business ist noch sehr, sehr kompliziert. Man muss aufpassen.
Ja, umso mehr ist man jetzt dazu angehalten, gerade bei einer Mission zur Sonne nachzudenken. Sonnenmissionen sind ja nicht besonders häufig. Es gibt ein paar, auch ein paar aktive. Was muss man da im Wesentlichen erwähnen? Was ist so die Geschichte der Sonnenmission?
Die Geschichte der Sonnenmission ist zuerst, da die Sonne relativ leicht zu beobachten ist vom Ferne. Das können wir jeden Tag, also nicht so häufig in Deutschland, aber in bestimmten Jahreszeiten schon. Die meisten Sonnenmissionen beobachten die Sonne von der Ferne, also zum Beispiel von der Erde umlaufbar, oder neulich in den letzten zehn, zwanzig Jahren Missionen, die in einem bestimmten Punkt relativ nah an die Erde und ein anderthalb Millionen Kilometer von der Erde, das heißt Lagrange-Punkt, es ist ein Äquilibriumpunkt zwischen Erde und Sonne. Da kann man sehr gut Sonnenmissionen platzieren.
Also da, wo sich die Anziehungskraft von Sonne und Erde quasi aufhebt und das Raumfahrzeug dann immer parallel mit der Erde mitführt, ohne sich kontrollieren zu müssen.
Genau. Also eigentlich ist es ein bisschen mehr kompliziert, aber es ist genau so, das ist sehr gut vereinfacht. Diese Missionen sind noch enorm weit weg von der Sonne. Also die Erde ist ungefähr 150 Millionen Kilometer, da ist man 48,5 Millionen Kilometer weit weg von der Sonne. Also die sind immer noch da. Das ist die Geschichte der Sonnenmission. Zum Beispiel, heutzutage sind zwei sehr interessante Satelliten der NASA, Stereo heißen die, die die Sonne gleichzeitig aus zwei verschiedenen Winkeln beobachten. Deswegen Stereo, wie unsere Augen. Also fantastische Missionen und sehr erfolgreich. Aber die sind immer noch in einer Entfernung wie die Erde, ungefähr 150 Millionen Kilometer. Auch praktisch auf der Erde Umlaufbahn, ein bisschen vorne, ein bisschen hinten. Aber die Missionen, die nah an die Sonne geflogen sind, sind sehr selten. Es gab eine Mission Mariner 10 in den 70er Jahren, die eigentlich als Ziel eine Flyby, also Vorbeiflug von Merkur hatte. Und sie hat das eigentlich gemacht und erfolgreich gemacht. Die flog relativ nah an die Sonne. Wir haben BepiColombo jetzt geplant und Solar Orbiter. Die Neuigkeit von Missionen wie Solar Orbiter ist, man geht dahin, wir fliegen dahin. Die NASA plant jetzt auch ein paar Missionen, die in den nächsten Jahren starten werden, die auch dieses Ziel haben, ein sehr nahe Vorbeiflug.
In Raumzeit 43 hatten wir auch genau diese Mission BepiColombo. Schon mal hier in Augenschein genommen, in Gespräch mit Elsa Montagnon, ihres Zeichens Star Spacecraft Operations Manager. Und da kam, also schon der Name der Mission ist ja schon ein Hinweis auf die Komplexität eines solchen Anflugs gewesen, da BepiColombo ja der Spitzname war von Giuseppe Colombo, der seinerzeit überhaupt erst mal herausgefunden hat, wie man da überhaupt hinkommt, also zum Merkur in dem Fall. Weil das fand ich dann auch ein sehr schönes, einen sehr schönen Vergleich, als ich dann im Nachgang auch über den Merkur nochmal gesprochen habe mit Tilman Spohn vom DLR, der das so verglichen mit, ja man muss so eine Murmel in einer Schüssel anschieben und dann in einer kleinen Lücke irgendwo in dieser Schüssel landen und da einfach den richtigen Weg zu finden, um überhaupt zum Merkur zu gelangen. Dazu kommt natürlich dann noch generell das Problem der Sonne, also nicht nur mit ihrer Anziehungskraft, sondern natürlich auch Hitze etc. Also das ist doch schon ein sehr komplexes Manöver, um da überhaupt erst hinzukommen.
Also genau, hinzukommen, wie du gesagt hast, das Problem ist die enorme Anziehungskraft der Sonne. Also man verlangsamt den Satelliten mit der Rakete, praktisch man schießt gegen die Richtung der Erde, also die Erde bewegt sich sehr schnell um die Sonne, ungefähr 30 km pro Sekunde. Man muss diese Geschwindigkeit der Sonde, des Satelliten reduzieren, also die Rakete.
Schon beim Start?
Schon beim Start.
Das heißt, man startet in eine andere Richtung als sonst?
Genau, man startet, um praktisch unsere orbitale Geschwindigkeit, diese 30 km pro Sekunde zu verlangsamen. Da fällt man an, praktisch Richtung Sonne zu fliegen, also praktisch man fällt zur Sonne. Aber da wird die Sonde unglaublich schnell, also praktisch beschleunigt und beschleunigt von dieser Anziehungskraft und da muss man natürlich diese Geschwindigkeit, wenn man an einen bestimmten Planeten kommen will und an beiden Planeten bleiben will, muss man das verlangsamen, damit dann die Anziehungskraft des kleinen Planeten, wie Merkur oder Venus, reicht, um die Sonne zu sich zu halten.
Also so ein bisschen so, als ob man vom Hochhaus springt und man möchte auch unten aufkommen, aber zwischendurch muss man sich immer wieder an irgendwelchen Seilen festhalten.
Genau, und zu verlangsamen. Das ist die erste Schwierigkeit. Deswegen brauchen diese Missionen diese Fly-Bys oder Swing-Bys, besser gesagt. Auf Deutsch heisst das auch Swing-Bye, weil das ist nochmal der Begriff. Genau, also Swing-Bye heißt, man fliegt in der Nähe eines Planeten. Und man benutzt die Schwerkraft des Planeten, um ein bisschen von unserer enormen orbitalen Energie weg von der Sonne zu nehmen, zu reduzieren. Normalerweise, wenn man Richtung Mars oder Jupiter oder so, da braucht man mehr Beschleunigung, mehr Energie. Man benutzt diesen Swing-Bye, um zu beschleunigen. Wenn man das richtig macht, Richtung Sonne, man benutzt Venus oder Merkur, so verlangsam zu machen, um die Sonne zu verlangsamen. Man verliert Energie und am Ende ist man in dieser niedrigen Umlaufbahn. Da hat man, in dem Fall von Solar Orbiter oder BepiColombo, das Ziel erreicht. Erste Schwierigkeit.
Wo muss man denn überall den Swing-Bye machen? Jetzt bei allen Planeten, die so auf dem Weg liegen? Ich meine, so viel sind es ja nicht. Es ist ja eigentlich nur die Venus.
Die Messenger zum Beispiel, eine NASA-Mission, die im Moment um den Merkur fliegt, die erste Mission, die eigentlich in eine geschlossene Umlaufbahn um den Merkur geflogen ist und ist noch da, hat beides zuerst Venus und auch Merkur benutzt. Ich glaube, die sind dreimal vorbei am Merkur geflogen, um zu verlangsamen. Am Ende hatten sie die richtige Geschwindigkeit, um in die Umlaufbahn zu kommen. Der BepiColombo wird das auch tun. Zuerst die Erde, dann ein Jahr später kommt dann die Venus und dann, ich glaube, das ist abhängig vom Start der Mission, das wir planen. Es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten, aber normalerweise mindestens drei, maximal fünfmal benutzt man Merkur, also ein Swing-By in der Nähe von Merkur, um zu verlangsamen bei BepiColombo. Solar Orbiter geht nicht zu Merkur, aber so nah an die Sonne wie Merkur, aber auf eine andere Umlaufbahn, wir werden nur die Erde und Venus benutzen.
So, das ist also das eigentliche Ziel, man möchte jetzt ran an die Sonne. Heißt das, dass das dann die sonnennächste Mission ist überhaupt, oder gab es schon mal andere, die sich ähnlich nah ran gewagt haben?
Ich glaube, da der Messenger und der Mariners, also ich weiss das nicht genau, aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir diejenigen sind, die am nächsten an die Sonne fliegen werden, weil es gibt schon zwei amerikanische Missionen, die zu Merkur waren, wir werden in minimaler Entfernung von der Sonne, die vergleichbar sind mit Merkur, also ich glaube, wir sind in dem gleichen Bereich, aber nicht unbedingt die ersten, die sich dann um die Sonne dreht. Genau, das ist die Neuigkeit, dass wir praktisch so nah an die Sonne kommen, mindestens ein Teil unserer Umlaufbahn. Am Ende, unsere Ziel-Umlaufbahn wird zwischen Entfernung von Merkur zu Entfernung von Venus fliegen, also eine elliptische Umlaufbahn, die ungefähr zwischen 0,3 astronomische Units einhalten, das heißt 0,3 ist 150 Millionen durch 30.
Der Abstand zur Erde sozusagen.
Genau, also ungefähr die 50 Millionen Kilometer und dann maximal Entfernung wird die von Venus. Also Venus ist ungefähr 100 Millionen Kilometer von der Sonne entfernt. Also wir fliegen diese elliptische Umlaufbahn.
Also ein Drittel bis zwei Drittel des Erdabstandes sozusagen.
Genau, genau. Und wenn wir nah an der Sonne sind, sind wir so schnell, dass wir praktisch fast so schnell wie die Sonnenoberfläche rotieren werden. Also wir werden praktisch wie ein geostationären Satelliten über die Erde immer die gleiche Fläche über eine bestimmte Zeit beobachten können. Das ist sehr, sehr wichtig. Man ist nah, man kann Nahaufnahmen nehmen, aber auch über eine bestimmte Zeit immer die gleiche Fläche beobachten. Und da sieht man natürlich die Sonnenoberfläche sehr aktiv, sehr beweglich. Und das ist eigentlich eine der Neuigkeiten der Mission, aber auch der schwierigsten Sache zu verwirklichen, auch von der Operationen-Seite.
Sonnenrotation ist ja so was wie 25, 26 Tage ungefähr. Das heißt, die Sonne selbst dreht sich um sich selbst so in etwas weniger als vier Wochen. Das heißt dann, dass der Solar Orbiter dann quasi die Hälfte davon, also ungefähr so zwei Wochen, relativ nah ist und darüber sozusagen über einen bestimmten Punkt ist. Aber wenn er dann wiederkommt, dann ist er immer wieder an einem anderen Punkt. Das heißt, man kann sukzessive...
Diese Umlaufbahn dauert sechs Monate. Alle sechs Monate kommen wir zwei bis drei Wochen in diesem Bereich, wo wir diese Nahaufnahmen nehmen können.
Ah ja, da wird es ganz schön heiß.
Das wird heiß, weil, aber vielleicht ist da ein bisschen zu detailliert für diese Besprechung, aber für uns sehr, sehr schwierig in den Operationen ist, also diese Sonde ist in dem Fall hunderte Millionen Kilometer, sagen wir ungefähr, im besten Fall 100 Millionen Kilometer weg. Und wir können nicht in Echtzeit mit dieser Sonde operieren. Wir müssen alles vorher planen, die Kommandos hochschicken und dann warten.
Also das Licht braucht ja sechs Minuten bis zur Erde.
Genau, schon das Licht, also schon diese zwei Reisen des Lichtsignals ist eine viertel Stunde fast und das ist schon sehr unpraktisch. Aber alles muss natürlich sehr genau kalkuliert und vorbereitet zuerst werden. Das heisst, in dieser Phase wollen die Wissenschaftler einen bestimmten Punkt auf der Oberfläche verfolgen. Und dieses Punkt, also die müssen schon eine Vorhersage der Bewegung dieses Punktes, weil wenn wir sagen, die Oberfläche rotiert in drei, vier Wochen, ist nur eine durchschnittliche Rotation. Die Oberfläche der Sonne ist nicht wie auf der Erde. Da ist es eine Gas- und Plasma-Umgebung, die unglaublich kompliziert ist, unglaublich aktiv ist und dynamisch. Also ein bestimmter Punkt, eine bestimmte Feature heisst das. Zum Beispiel ein Magnetfeld, das rauskommt, oder eine Sonnenflecke zum Beispiel. Die wollen das beobachten. Die wissen ungefähr, wie schnell sie sich bewegt und in welche Richtung. Aber nicht genau. Das muss vorhergesagt werden. Und wir müssen die Lage-Regelung unseres Satelliten so programmieren, dass er diese Vorhersage verfolgt. Aber die Vorhersage ist nicht genau. Also praktisch alle 12 bis 24 Stunden müssen wir das wieder programmieren und korrigieren. Und wir wissen es nicht, also wir können das nicht selbst korrigieren. Wir müssen die Wissenschaftler in diesen Prozess reinholen. Das heißt, das Prozess ist, Kommandos hochschicken, Bilder nehmen, Daten zurücknehmen, zu den Wissenschaftlern schicken. Die Wissenschaftler schauen sich die Bilder, erkennen, wo ist eigentlich ihre interessante Tone und dann neue Vorhersage zu uns, die Daten schicken, wir planen die neue Lageregelung, hoch zum Satelliten schicken und so weiter. Dieses Prozess muss einen Tag nehmen. Wir verhandeln im Moment Ende Januar. Nächste Woche haben wir eine sehr wichtige Besprechung mit den Wissenschaftlern, wo wir praktisch sagen, Leute, ihr möchtet dieses Prozess so schnell wie möglich haben. Wir können das maximal so schnell machen. Können wir jetzt Ideen oder bestimmte Prozesse besser entwickeln, damit ihr schnell zu uns kommt oder wir schneller reagieren kommen? Sehr kompliziert, im Moment sind wir noch nicht da. Wir haben eine ideelle Reaktionszeit von drei Tagen, also End-to-End, dieses Prozess. Sie wollen einen Tag, den wir jetzt verhandeln müssen. Es ist keine kommerzielle oder politische Verhandlung, es ist eine technische und wissenschaftliche Verhandlung.
Das ist auch ein ganz neuer Prozess, weil das ist ja bei anderen Missionen nicht so.
Für uns ist es total neu.
Für die Wissenschaftler ja auch.
Für die Wissenschaftler besonders. Sie sind daran gewöhnt, ihre Daten zu kriegen und dann vielleicht eine PhD-Arbeit zu starten. Am Ende kommen die Ergebnisse. Hier muss man natürlich keine PhD-Arbeit in einem Tag machen, aber die müssen lernen, die wichtigen Ergebnisse, was wir brauchen, um die neue Lageregelung zu programmieren, schnell zu liefern. In einem Tag oder in zwölf Stunden oder so. Das Prozess ist ganz neu für uns. Es ist die Herausforderung von Solar Orbiter. Sonst ist die Mission für uns relativ normal, sagen wir. Es ist eine normale interplanetäre Mission mit den normalen Herausforderungen, die wir schon normal wie so etwas sein können.
Das hast du vorhin schon gesagt, dass mit den Wettersatelliten und so weiter. Daran haben wir uns gewöhnt. Aber die Fernerkundung ist ja eigentlich immer wieder was Neues.
Man kann so sagen, in Europa bis jetzt, in den letzten zehn Jahren, sind drei interplanetäre Satelliten gestartet worden. Es sind unsere, die werden alle hier von ESO kontrolliert. Es ist, sagen wir, in meinem Bereich sind 50 Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen. Das sind die Einzigen, die wissen, was das bedeutet, in Europa interplanetäre Missionen zu fliegen. Und wenn wir sagen, es ist normal, das heißt, wir haben das dreimal gemacht. Da sieht man den Unterschied mit Fernmelde-Satelliten oder meteorologische oder Erdbeobachtungssatelliten. Das sind ganze Reihen. Ich weiss nicht, die Astra in Luxemburg vielleicht betreibt 30 Satelliten. Ich weiss nicht. Hier haben wir in zehn Jahren drei Sonden gestartet. Und da füllen wir uns als Super-Experte. Wir sind die Super-Experten in Europa, aber es ist immer noch begrenzt. Und da draußen ist so viel zu lernen und so viele Überraschungen auch. Das ist alles, was wir haben.
Wie weit ist denn überhaupt die Sonnenforschung? Es gibt ja bestimmte Objekte, die sind unter besonderer Beobachtung. Also bei Mars merkt man das jetzt gerade besonders. Alle zwei Jahre gibt es ja immer die Möglichkeit, dorthin zu gehen. Und es vergeht eigentlich kein Slot, wo nicht auch wirklich eine Mission, wenn nicht gleich sogar mehrere, gestartet werden. Von der ESA, von der NASA. Und wie wir ja zuletzt auch gesehen haben, mit einigen Erfolg, auch wenn gerade die Mars-Missionen auch schon eben gerade angedeutet haben, auch immer von besonderem Pech verfolgt sind. Aber es sind halt so viele, dass da eben sich die Wissenschaft auch wirklich darauf konzentriert. Und natürlich auch Venus und die anderen Planeten sind unter permanenter Beobachtung. Die Sonne ist natürlich auch unter permanenter Beobachtung, weil sie ja sowieso immer so gut zu sehen ist. Aber was verspricht man sich denn jetzt an wissenschaftlichen Durchbruch? Und was sind sozusagen die wirklich großen Erkenntnisbereiche, wo man so hin will mit dieser Solar Orbiter-Mission? Warum muss man jetzt so nah ran? Warum kann man nicht auch in größerem Abstand drum herum fliegen?
Also zuerst muss man sagen, es ist weniger vergleichbar, die, sagen wir, die neue, die Forschung zur Sonne mit der Forschung der Planeten, die Sonne war immer so, also seit Lange, seit Jahrhunderte, geforscht. Das kann man sehr gut von der Erde beobachten. Man kann die Corona durch Sonnenfinsternis schon sehr gut untersuchen. Also es gab schon eine Menge Daten über die Sonne vor der Satelliten-Ära. Mit den Planeten kannte man kaum etwas. Es waren kleine Bilder von Teleskopen. Die Satelliten haben praktisch eine Revolution hervorgebracht, als sie in der Nähe der Planeten geflogen sind. Zweitens will ich sagen, sehr wichtig in der Sonnenforschung ist nicht nur, da hinzufliegen, sondern aus bestimmten Sichtpunkten und Entfernungen und Bereichen gleichzeitig zu messen. Man hat das gelernt, also die Beziehungen zwischen Sonne und Erde sind viel tiefer und viel komplizierter, als man vor der Satelliten-Ära gedacht hatte. Es ist nicht nur dieser sehr weite Stern, 150 Millionen Kilometer, die praktisch elektromagnetische Strahlung zu uns schickt. Dieses Magnetfeld, das von der Sonne rauskommt, ist sehr eng verbunden mit dem Magnetfeld der Erde. Die Störungen oder die Dynamik des Magnetfeldes der Sonne verursacht sehr komplette Prozesse in unserer Magnetosphäre. Und man denkt heute auch in der niedrigen Atmosphäre, also die Stratosphäre oder so. Das heißt, wichtig ist nicht nur dahin zu fliegen wie bei einem Planeten. Bei einem Planeten ist die Gleichung, je näher desto besser. Wenn ich landen kann, ist es sogar besser. Das ist sehr einfach. Bei der Sonne ist wichtiger, bestimmte Sonden, zum Beispiel Sonden um die Erde, die das Magnetfeld der Erde messen können oder unter Beobachtung halten können, sondern die permanent die ganze Sonne beobachten, die ganze Dynamik der Corona, von diesen enormen Sternen. Es ist 1,5 Mio. groß. Von der Ferne ist auch wichtig, man sieht das Ganze. Und Sonden, die in der Nähe sind und die punktuelle Hochauflösungen, Beobachtungen machen können. Diese Beziehung von verschiedenen Sichtpunkten, also auch zum Beispiel Sonden, die über die Sonne und unter die Sonne fliegen, das klingt ein bisschen komisch, aber alle Sonden mit Ausnahme von einer europäischen Sonde der 90er-Jahre, Ulysses, haben die Sonne nur, und natürlich alle Teleskopen von der Erde, haben die Sonne nur von der Seite beobachtet.
Von der Schicht, wo die Planeten sind.
Ja, die ägyptische Ebene, sagen wir die Seite. Also wir sehen immer, die Sonne dreht sich, aber die dreht sich in eine Richtung, und wir sehen immer diese Seite, die. Äquatorielle Ansicht. Die Polen sind relativ wenig bekannt. In einem Magnetfeld sind die Polen natürlich sehr wichtig, wie bei der Erde. Nur einmal in der Geschichte der Raumfahrt ist jemand, und in der Geschichte der Menschheit, ist jemand über die Sonne und unter die Sonne geflogen, das war die Ulysses, sechsmal, glaube ich, haben wir das gemacht. 20 Jahre lang hat Ulysses, nein, es war nicht sechsmal, ich glaube, die Umlaufbahn dauerte sechs Jahre, das heisst, mindestens dreimal um die Sonne ist sie geflogen. Wie gesagt, das hat so viel gebracht, obwohl die Sonne sehr weit weg über die Sonne war, also weiter weg als die Erde. Aber diese Aussicht von oben und von unten war einmalig. Und die Messungen gleichzeitig mit den Erdteleskopen und mit den normalen Satelliten waren so unschätzbar.
Auf welcher Bahn wird denn der Solar Orbiter um die Sonne herum orbiten? Auch wieder in der normalen Äkryptik?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das ist auch eine Besonderheit der Mission. Ich habe vorher die Swing-Bys erwähnt, um dahin zu kommen. Aber was wir machen werden, ist, während der Wissenschaftsphase werden wir weitere Swing-Bys von der Venus machen und wir benutzen die Venus nicht um die Sonde zu beschleunigen oder zu verlangsamen, sondern um die Neigung der Umlaufbahn, um die Sonne zu ändern. Und wir werden diese Neigung, mit alle anderthalb Jahren praktisch, können wir die der Nähe eigentlich auch öfter. Wenn wir in der Nähe der Venus kommen, können wir einen Swing-By machen und unsere Neigung ändern. Und wir kommen bis zu, ich glaube, 35 Grad Nord auf der ekliptischen Ebene. Also wir ändern die Neigung von 35 Grad. Man könnte das weitermachen. Im Prinzip kann die Mission viel länger dauern. Im Moment ist die Mission so geplant, dass wir das so...
Das heißt, über die Zeit gewinnt man sozusagen immer wieder eine andere Perspektive.
Genau, genau.
Und kann das immer wieder anschauen. Und natürlich diese große Ellipse hat man ja auch noch einen anderen Vorteil, wie ich vermute. Also wir könnten ja auch gleich noch mal ein bisschen auf die Instrumente zu sprechen kommen. Aber ich nehme mal an, das Magnetfeld dürfte ja auch im Mittelpunkt stehen. Und gerade das wird sich ja besonders dann gut messen lassen, wenn man sozusagen uns aus unterschiedlichen Abständen herausverfolgt. Und das dann eben auch rundrum, sodass man dann im Idealfall so eine komplette Karte hat. Sofern sowas bei so einem wabernden Objekt überhaupt möglich ist. Ich weiß gar nicht, inwiefern man da irgendwas als stabil ansehen kann.
Genau, Karte kann man, obwohl natürlich als Vergleich ist natürlich richtig, dann über eine Karte kann man nicht sprechen, weil die Sonne so dynamisch ist. Aber über bestimmte Phasen der Sonne und auch Gebiete des Sonnenwindes und der Corona kann man natürlich dann sich ein Modell bauen, das sich bewegt. Auch die Dynamik dieses Modells kann man das reinbauen. Es ist keine statische Karte, sondern ein dynamisches Modell.
Die Sonne ist ja auch ein sehr dynamisches Objekt. Unter anderem gibt es ja überhaupt so die Gesamtsonnenaktivität, schwankt ja über die Zeit. Es gibt immer wieder die aktiveren Phasen, es gibt die schwächeren Phasen. Derzeit sind wir in einer schwächeren Phase, die auch relativ lange andauert. Das heißt, die Erwartungen, die man bisher hatte, bestätigen sich gerade nur sehr eingeschränkt. Ist das auch so etwas, wo man sich einen Erkenntnisgewinn verspricht?
Sicher, ich bin kein Sonnenwissenschaftler. Aber bestimmt diese schwache Phase und diese lange Phase, die Länge dieser schwachen Phase, hat viele Wissenschaftler überrascht. Zum Punkt, dass heute man sich fragt, was passiert in der nächsten Zyklus. Bis jetzt hat man diesen 11 Jahre Zyklus als Selbstverständlichkeit betrachtet. Niemand weiss genau, woher das kommt, aber es ist einfach so. Man will natürlich verstehen, warum dieser Zyklus, warum gerade 11 Jahre, aber jetzt sieht man ein Zyklus, das ganz anders ist. Und man hat in der Geschichte der Erde, wenn man geologisch untersucht und auch meteorologische Untersuchungen, zum Beispiel in dem Packeis oder so, kann man schon erkennen, dass dieser Zyklus nicht so regelmäßig war. Also mit einer der Ziele der Sonnenwissenschaft ist natürlich zu verstehen, was ist dieser Zyklus, wie entwickelt sich das und besonders, was für Einflüsse hat dieser Sonnenzyklus auf die Erde.
Vielleicht können wir mal so ein bisschen auf die Instrumentierung von Solar Orbiter zu sprechen kommen. Das ist ja eigentlich immer so das Spannende. Also hinfliegen ist das eine, aber wenn man dann vor Ort ist, und ich nehme mal an, hier wird es ganz klassisch auch so eine Kalibrierungsphase geben bei der Ankunft, oder vielleicht auch vorher schon. Irgendwann ist dann alles betriebsbereit und man will dann eben auch Daten haben. Was erzeugt denn alles? Daten auf dem Solar Orbiter?
Also wir haben so viele Instrumente wie möglich. Ich glaube bei Solar Orbiter sind zehn Instrumente. Was wichtig ist, ist, dass die in zwei Familien geteilt sind. Und die sind auch sehr wichtig. Und ich werde jetzt erklären, diese Teilung ist sehr, sehr wichtig. Es sind zwei Welten von Wissenschaft, aber auch von der Operation, also Missionsbetrieb, auch ein sehr wichtiger Unterschied. Die In-Situ-Instrumente sind die ersten, die eingeschaltet werden. Das heisst, In-Situ messen etwas, das in der Umgebung der Sonne ist. Magnetfelder, Partikel, die von der Sonne kommen, energetische Partikel natürlich. Und das kann man schon während der Reise machen. Das heisst, diese Instrumente funktionieren praktisch vom Start. Also nicht genau vom Start, wie bei allen anderen wissenschaftlichen Missionen. Wir starten, wir testen zuerst ein paar Tage alle Systeme. Dann schalten wir langsam an die Instrumente, die dann operiert werden müssen. Ein paar Kalibrationen, ein paar Tests. Und dann können die losgehen. Also wissenschaftliche Daten werden voraussichtlich vier bis sechs Wochen nach dem Start schon geliefert werden von diesen Instrumenten. Die andere Familie ist, was wir Remote-Sensing-Instrumente nennen, das sind praktisch Kameras. Also die machen Bilder in verschiedenen Wellenlängen, in verschiedenen Bereichen. UV, Optisch und Röntgenstrahlung sogar. Die sind natürlich mehr gedacht für die kleinere Entfernungen, also Bilder von der Erdeumlaufbahn, besser gemacht von anderen Satelliten, die viel schwerere und größere Instrumente an Bord haben. Unsere kleine und relativ leichte Instrumente sind so gedacht, um weit wegzukommen, weit wegzufliegen. Und die werden funktionieren nur in der späteren Phase und nur in bestimmten Bereichen, wo wir nah an der Sonne sind und gleichzeitig mit der Sonne rotieren können. Da werden wir die Remote Sensing Instrumente einsetzen. Während der Reise werden wir sie auch manchmal prüfen, ob die noch in Ordnung sind, ein paar Kalibrationen durchführen. Aber ihre Arbeit fängt an erst drei bis vier Jahre nach dem Start, wo wir wirklich in unsere neue, zweite Phase der Mission sind. Also wir haben bestimmte Zeitfenster, wo wir in der Nähe der Sonne sind.
Aber dieses Remote Sensing wird dann aber auch schon durchgehend über die gesamte Ellipse in der abschließenden Umlaufbahn durchgeführt oder auch immer nur, wenn man in der Nähe ist?
Im Prinzip könnte man das Problem, und das ist noch eine Schwierigkeit, ist, dass diese Instrumente eine enorme Menge Daten liefern. Also ich rede jetzt von Terabytes oder liefern können. Da wir so weit weg von der Erde fliegen, haben wir sehr, sehr schmale Bandbreiten. Schmale Bandbreiten. Das heißt, unsere Sonnenwissenschaftler sind so daran gewöhnt, in der Nähe der Erde zu fliegen, zum Beispiel auf Soho, eineinhalb Millionen Kilometer weg, Sonde immer da mit einer Antenne gerichtet auf die Erde. Sie können sehr einfach Instrumente fliegen, die enorme Datenmengen zurückschicken. Die gleichen Wissenschaftler jetzt bauen Instrumente für Solar Orbiter und die im Prinzip die gleiche Datenmengen bekommen möchten. Sie können das vergessen. Aber die Instrumente produzieren diese Datenmengen. Das heisst, wir werden sie nur in bestimmten interessanten Bereichen, zwei, drei Wochen lang, ich glaube wir planen ungefähr zweimal in der Umlaufbahn, zwei oder dreimal in einer zwei Wochen Periode, wo wir Daten sammeln. Und dann, in diese sechs Monate Umlaufbahn, dann benutzen wir die Zeit, um die Daten zurückzuschicken zu Erde. Also alles wird gesammelt in einem On-Board Memory, also ein Speicher von, nicht viel, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht mehr, ein paar hunderte Gigabytes.
Das ist ja schon eine Menge, im Vergleich zu Missionen, wie sie vor 10, 20 Jahren geflogen sind.
Sicher, aber diese Instrumente könnten im Prinzip diese Speicher in einem Tag schon füllen.
Geht man dann nicht schon dazu über, vor Ort, also auf dem Gerät selber eine Auslese zu machen? Wäre das möglich?
Das wird auch passieren. Auslese ist vielleicht... Ja, zum Beispiel habe ich vorher dieses schnelle Prozess erklärt. Eine der Lösungen ist, Thumbnails zu machen. Wir sind daran gewöhnt im Webbereich. Also kleine Bilder, kleine Samples, kleine Bilder, die die wichtigsten Daten liefern, um zu sehen, wo ist dieser Feature. Nicht die ganze Wissenschaft. Die programmieren diese Thumbnails, schicken sie runter und dann können wir dann das ganze programmieren. Dann werden die echten, großen Bilder gemacht in die richtige Richtung. Also das wird gemacht. Ein anderer Bereich, das on board gemacht wird, ist natürlich Datenkomprimierung. Das sind wirklich normale Algorithmen, die auch auf der Erde benutzt werden. Die können viel Sprecherplatz sparen und das wird gemacht. Aber mehr als das schwere ich jetzt on board. Also wir haben noch keine elektronischen Wissenschaftler, die on board sitzen und sagen, oh das ist wichtig, das ist schön.
Ja, das ist knifflig. Eigentlich bräuchte man so Daten-Hubs im All, die so auf kürzerer Strecke höhere Übertragungsraten immer wieder für alle Missionen bereitstellen könnten. Aber dafür gibt es dann einfach zu wenig Missionen.
Zu wenig Missionen und wie gesagt, die Entfernung ist immer noch das Problem. Am Ende auch diese Daten-Hubs brauchen große Antenne, brauchen viel Energie und ja, das ist schwierig. Was natürlich, aber das ist nicht nur ein Problem für Solar Orbiter, es ist besonders schwierig für Solar Orbiter, aber auch für andere interplanetare Missionen. Heutzutage die Instrumente können viel mehr tun, als wir uns leisten können in der Daten-Bandbreite. Natürlich versucht man, unsere Ingenieure auch hier in ESOC oder die Entwickler von Satellitensystemen, versuchen jetzt in anderen Wellenlängerbereich zu gehen. Zuerst, im Moment arbeiten wir in dem Mikrowellenbereich. Wir sind schon bei Interplanetary-Missionen von der S-Band, das ist ungefähr 2 Gigahertz, schon im Bereich 6 bis 8 Gigahertz gegangen, das ist die X-Band. Und jetzt werden Missionen gestartet, Stereo ist eine davon und Beppi Colombo wird das haben, die schon KA-Band haben an Bord und KA-Band ist schon im Bereich 20 bis 30 Gigahertz, sind noch Mikrowellen, 40 Gigahertz ist das so. Bis 40, ok, das, ich glaube wir benutzen 26, 30, ok, es ist relativ eine grosse Bandbreite, aber die, die wichtig ist, dass je höher die Frequenz, umso mehr Daten transportiert werden können.
Aber umso schwieriger ist es auch, das zu empfangen.
Genau, dass die, die Genauigkeit der, der Ausrichtung ist sehr, sehr wichtig, da eine, ein Bruchteil von einem Grad, also Fehler, dann verliert man das Signal. Und dazu, in der Atmosphäre, die, die, wenn es regnet, oder sogar wenn die, wenn eine Wolke dazwischenkommt, kann die, die, diese, diese Eudatenübertragung so zerstören. Also diese Ka-Band haben wir wenig Erfahrung, kaum. Wir hatten eine, eine Mission zum Mond in 2000, Anfang des Jahrhunderts, probiert mit Ka-Band, aber viel Erfahrung haben wir nicht, aber das ist schwierig.
Gibt es denn da ein Fallback, dass wenn man feststellt, dass es irgendwie mit Ka-Band zu viele Probleme gibt, dass man dann umsteigen kann, auch auf das X-Band, oder gibt es da nur das eine?
Ja, Bepi Colombo fliegt beide, fliegt mit beiden X-Band und Ka-Band zum Merkur. Und wir haben alles geplant, damit praktisch die ganze Mission, also das minimale Ziel, mit X-Band erreicht wird von Bepi Colombo. Aber natürlich mit Ka-Band können wir drei- bis viermal mehr Daten zurückbringen und das werden wir tun. Ich wollte noch erwähnen, in diesem Bereich, unsere Kollegen im anderen Gebäude, die Ground Station Engineering Leute, die denken schon voraus in optische Data-Links. Also man kann, also optisch natürlich ist auch elektromagnetische Strahlung, aber in sehr hoher Frequenz. Und da kann man eine enorme Menge Daten... Das wird schon in der Nähe der Erde gemacht. Besonders es gibt Inter-Satellite-Links, also Verbindungen mit Laser-Kommunikation zwischen zwei Satelliten. Das funktioniert ganz gut. Interplanetarisch ist das noch nicht gemacht worden, aber man kann das im Prinzip tun.
Aber müsste man dann nicht die Empfangsstationen auch bei uns im Orbit vorhalten?
Man hat praktisch das gleiche Problem wie KA., eine Wolke, und dann ist das Signal vorbei. Bei KA ist es nur eine Störung. Also Teleskope in hohen Bereichen wie Chile oder so, in den Bergen oder so sind natürlich eine Lösung.
Wäre es auch eine Option, etwas im Orbit der Erde fortzuführen?
Das ist auch eine Option. Das ist sicher ein Satellit, das zuständig ist für die Verbindungen zu interpretaren Missionen. Da ist natürlich keine Wolke dazwischen. Und dann dieses Satellit durch die Nähe an der Erde mit einer höheren Bandbreite.
Und vor allem auch mit mehr Speicher. Aber gibt es so etwas schon?
Im Moment nicht.
Aber das ist so eine Überlegung.
Ja, sicher. Es gibt sogar zwei Parteien. Diejenigen, die sagen, mit Bodenteleskopen funktioniert das ganz gut. Und wir bauen diese schönen Teleskopen, zum Beispiel auf der Kanarischen Insel oder Hawaii oder Chile. Also schöne Gegenden.
Strand in der Nähe passt schon.
Und andere, die sagen, man braucht einen Satelliten. Okay, jetzt mache ich Scherze. Aber es sind nicht Überlegungen. Es sind wirklich Bereiche, wo viele Leute jetzt arbeiten. Und es kommt in der Zukunft. Ich würde sagen, wir sind noch weit weg. Die KA, zum Beispiel, ist noch nicht akzeptiert worden. Die kommt. Und danach kommt die optische.
Aber es gibt auch noch gar nicht so viele Teleskope, die überhaupt in diesem KA-Band arbeiten können, oder? Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, als wir hier über das S-Trek-Netzwerk gesprochen haben, da ist ja, sagen wir mal, der Wandel zum X-Band, das ist ja das, was jetzt gerade eigentlich auf der Agenda steht.
Ja, eigentlich, okay, wenn wir reden Interplanetar, haben wir, es ist schon passiert, die erste Antenne, die wir gebaut haben in Australien, also Interplanetar heißt große Antenne, 35 Meter.
Diese dicken Schlüssel.
Genau, im Fall von ESA, wir haben drei Antennen jetzt gebaut in den letzten zehn Jahren, zwölf Jahren. In Australien die erste.
In Perth?
In Perth, eigentlich New Norcia, ist 150 Kilometer nördlich von Perth. Und die wurde für S-Band und X-Band gebaut. Jetzt ist die S-Band weg, besonders weil unsere Mobiltelefonen die S-Band benutzen. Und natürlich, wenn man bei der ITU, dieser Internationalen Telekommunikationsorganisation, einen Konflikt hat zwischen Weltraumforschung und Mobilfunk, guess who wins? Die S-Band ist jetzt Geschichte. Wir benutzen das immer noch. Rosetta hat S-Band, aber als Emergency. Das heißt, als Backup. Normalerweise benutzen wir S-Band. Dann wurde die Cebreros-Antenne gebaut in Spanien. Nur mit S-Band, also keine S-Band, das war schon vorbei, das war zwei Jahre später, fünf Jahre später. S-Band und KA. Im Moment haben wir KA-Empfang, also kein KA-Senden, aber das ist nicht so wichtig, Empfang ist wichtiger.
Bei Senden ist ja im Wesentlichen ein Telekommando, das ist keine hohe Datenrate.
Genau, da brauchen wir wirklich nicht so viel. Dritte Bodenstation, gerade Nagelneue. Wir fangen an, das jetzt im Januar zu benutzen. Sie wurde Mitte Dezember eingeweiht. In Argentinien, Malargue heißt das, auch X-Band, KA-Band in Empfang. Also wir sind bereit mit KA, aber keine Senden bis der Start von Bepe Colombo.
Aber es gibt sozusagen nur diese beiden Antennen?
Ja, die NASA hat in ihrem Komplexe, die drei Komplexe, die haben viel mehr Antennen, und die NASA hat in jeder eine Antenne, die KA hat, mindestens eine Antenne.
Okay, und die kann auch mit verwendet werden im Rahmen der internationalen Kooperation. Das ist ja selbstverständlich. So, 2017 geht es los, wenn alles klappt. Das weiß man ja vorher immer nicht so genau. Kann ja irgendwas passieren, braucht nur irgendeine Rakete oder ein Raketensystem ein Problem zu haben. Schon verschiebt sich das für alle Beteiligten. Ich glaube, geplant ist es aber, eine amerikanische Rakete zum Start zu nehmen. Eine Delta-Rakete, glaube ich. Aber es gibt auch ein Backup.
Wir haben immer, also seitdem wir ganze Missionen verschieben mussten, weil eben nur ein Problem mit einer bestimmten Serie von Raketen gab, dann hat die ESA darauf bestanden, jede Mission muss geplant werden mit einem Backup-Träger. Wir arbeiten jetzt mit Ariane 5 als Backup-Träger. Warum Backup? Weil das kostet Geld. Diese internationale Kooperation mit den Amerikanern, kriegen wir diese Rakete umsonst. Wir liefern wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse. Das ist sowieso interessant. Die Wissenschaft ist eine globale Community. Wir liefern Daten. Wir tragen ein paar Instrumente der Amerikaner mit uns. Sie geben uns zum Beispiel die Rakete. Das ist gut für das Projekt, für die internationale Kooperation. Wenn das schief geht, dann müssen wir uns selbst eine Rakete kaufen. Das kann nur die Ariane 5 in diesem Fall, diese Mission bis zur Sonne zu bringen. Man braucht eine sehr starke Rakete. Das wird eine Menge Geld kosten. Natürlich, in einem Extremfall wird das gemacht. Wenn die Mission schon bereit ist, und dann die Rakete nicht da ist, oder die Kooperation platzt, glaube ich nicht.
Was hat denn das für Auswirkungen auf die Missionsplanung? Wenn man jetzt in den USA startet, dann geht es wahrscheinlich von Cape Canaveral los. Das ist ja dann ein ganz anderer Startpunkt, als wenn man jetzt in Kourou startet. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel das ausmacht. Aber letzten Endes, bei so einem harklein, ausgerechneten Gesamtkurs, ist das doch auch schon ein Unterschied in Bezug auf Geschwindigkeit, die man erzählt, etc.?
Absolut. Also im Moment, die Leute, wie der Markus Landgraf, nicht in diesem Fall, ist ein Kollege von ihm, arbeiten an verschiedenen Trajectories, also verschiedene Wegrouten, Wege. Es gibt einige, die sind abhängig von Starttag. Es gibt Möglichkeiten im Januar 2017, es gibt Möglichkeiten später in dem Jahr, es gibt Möglichkeiten im Jahr 2018. Wir haben verschiedene Zeitfenster, wo wir starten können. Weil die Konstellation der einzelnen Planeten untereinander wichtig ist. Wir müssen auf einen bestimmten Planeten zielen, normalerweise in diesem Fall Venus. Da haben wir keine große Auswahl. Es gibt Zeitfenster. Sagen wir, ein bis zwei Mal im Jahr kann man das tun. Und wie eng ist das Zeitfenster? Es gibt immer bei jeder Lösung, bei jeder Weg, die wir gefunden haben, gibt es einen Zeitpunkt, der ideal ist. Und dann um diesen Zeitpunkt fängt man an, weniger effizient zu fliegen. Das heisst, man hat weniger Schub von der Rakete, also nicht in die richtige Richtung. Oder man braucht mehr, also im Prinzip kann man weniger Masse ins All bringen. Und wir planen normalerweise 30 Tage. Das heisst, es gibt einen ideellen Punkt. Und wir planen 15 Tage vorher, 15 Tage danach. Um zu vermeiden, also es ist eine Daumenregel. 30 Tage sind normalerweise gut.
Das heisst, man hat letztendlich so eine Karte, wo man sagt, wir könnten innerhalb dieser 30 Tage starten, aber wenn wir um 10 Tage verschoben werden, dann haben wir schon die und die Einbuße, müssen gegebenenfalls auch mit weniger Treibstoff starten etc. Und dann muss irgendjemand entscheiden, okay, machen wir das jetzt oder warten wir noch ein halbes Jahr.
Genau, genau. Und was wollte ich sagen? Ja, also die Abhängigkeit von Starttag oder Zeitpunkt, aber auch von der Rakete. Die Rakete hat nicht nur einen unterschiedlichen geografischen Startpunkt, sondern auch verschiedene Performance, also Leistung. Man muss die ganze Trajektore wieder kalkulieren.
Nichts ist austauschbar. Nichts ist ohne Weiteres austauschbar.
Man muss wirklich vieles gerechnet mit einrichten. Ja, und wenn bei uns in der ESO, bei jeder Mission, in dieser Studienphase, die jetzt schon vorbei ist, ein bestimmtes Dokument gebaut wird, das heißt CREMA, Consolidated Report and Mission Analysis, also die Analyse der Mission. Und bei einfachen Missionen kommt eine Umlaufbahn, man fliegt um die Erde, ein Telekom-Satellite oder so, ganz einfach. Bei so einer Mission wie Solar Orbiter haben wir fünf oder sechs verschiedene Missionen in dem gleichen Dokument, verschiedene Trägerakete, verschiedene Startpunkte usw. Das muss man tun. Und dann gibt es der Tag, wo die sagen, ah, jetzt Ende dieser Mission, fängt die neue an.
Das ist ja auch immer die Herausforderung bei dieser Mission. Ich merke das immer wieder bei den Gesprächen, wie eigentlich auch diese Komplexität der Aufgabe, das hohe Risiko natürlich auch, was man dabei hat, die große Anspannung, wenn es dann so weit ist, beziehungsweise auch die schwierigen Momente, wenn mal wieder was gerettet werden muss. Gerade hier im letzten Gespräch mit Markus Kirsch haben wir über diese Phase gesprochen, wo XMM Newton acht Tage nicht zu erreichen war. Das ist sehr schlimm. Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Das hat mich auch alle unglaublich belastet, weil einfach so viel dran hängt. Aber dann eben auch so die Freude, dann eine Lösung gefunden zu haben, die er dann am Ende auch gegriffen hat, das sind wahrscheinlich unbeschreibliche Momente.
Das ist das Schönste in Mission Operations zu arbeiten. Man ist da an der Front. Und alles passiert da am Ende. Die Fehler, die gemacht wurden, vielleicht vor zehn Jahren, bei anderen oder bei uns selbst, am Ende kommen in diesem Moment. Wir zahlen alle Fehler, nicht nur unsere, sondern auch die Fehler der Entwickler, die Fehler der Wissenschaftler. Und wir müssen Lösungen finden. Es ist unglaublich, und das ist wirklich eine schöne Eigenschaft unserer Arbeit, unglaublich, wie kreativ die Leute werden können, wenn sie in eine ganz neue Schwierigkeit stecken. Und eine ganze Mission kann wieder programmiert werden. Wir machen Sachen mit den Satelliten, die vor dem Start undenkbar wären. Als Beispiel, wir fliegen Cluster. Cluster sind vier Satelliten, sehr einfache Satelliten, sind praktisch Zylinder, die um sich selbst drehen, also mit den Solarzellen um die Oberfläche des Zylinders. Und die sind sehr alt, die fliegen zweimal im Jahr in der Schatten der Erde, und die haben Batterien dafür. Die Batterien sind alle kaputt. Was machen wir jetzt? Die Satelliten sterben in dieser Schatten, praktisch alles wird automatisch ausgeschaltet, kein Strom mehr. Aber dann kommen die raus wieder, die sind stabil, weil die sich um sich selbst drehen. Die kommen raus aus der Schatten, und die Computer langsam, nicht ganz sauber, wieder starten. Unsere Leute am Boden haben neue Prozeduren entwickelt für die Vorbereitung. Also die schalten alle Relays und alles Computer vor dieser Schattenphase in eine bestimmte Konfiguration, die die Wahrscheinlichkeit maximiert, dass nach der Schattenphase die Computer wieder einschalten. Und das machen wir mit vier Satelliten, Dutzende von Eklipsis, also von dieser Schattenphase pro Jahr. Und das funktioniert. Die Satelliten wurden mit Batterien gebaut. Hätten wir vor zehn Jahren nach vorn gesagt, ja, diese Batterien benutzen wir nicht. Die Leute hätten gesagt, ihr seid verrückt. Es funktioniert ganz gut. Und die Leute werden so kreativ und so. Es ist fantastisch.
Ja, es ist bewundernswert, weil auch so viel gerettet werden kann. Also einerseits das Verhindern, dass etwas scheitert, andererseits auch das Verlängern von Missionen.
Was du erwähnt hast von dem Markus Kirch, diese XMM-Fehler, das ist das Schlimmste, das uns passieren kann, dass wir die Signale verlieren. Ich habe das schon gesagt, das ist der Alptraum von einem Mission-Controller. Ich habe kein Signal, da kann ich nichts tun. Und ich versuche, das Signal wiederzukriegen. Aber alles, was ich mache, habe ich keine Ahnung, ob das was bewirkt, ob das empfangen wird oder nicht. Ich verliere sehr schnell die Übersicht. Also sowas ist das Schlimmste, das uns passieren kann. In allen anderen Fällen, wenn ich ein Signal, nur eine schwache Radiowelle kriege, auch keine Telemetrie, dann weiß ich, dass ich was damit tun kann. Es ist neulich auch bei Cluster passiert, diese Mission, die jetzt ohne Batterien passiert. Manchmal kommen sie raus aus den Schatten und haben einen Computer in einem Zustand, der praktisch nur bestimmte Kommandos kriegt und nur ein Signal, ein Carrier, also ein Tu-So-Schick. Nichts Weiteres. Das erste Mal, dass es passiert wurde, haben wir 28 Stunden ohne Unterbrechung gearbeitet, um zu verstehen, was passiert wurde. Dann haben sie das verstanden, sie haben eine Prozedur entwickelt. Es ist weiter fünfmal passiert und in einer halben Stunde haben wir alles gelöst. Das ist so eine, was kann ich sagen?
Große Befriedigung bei der Arbeit auf jeden Fall.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Nach den 48 Stunden kommt man nach Hause und man sagt, Gott, ich habe was wirklich bewertet. Ich habe die Welt gerettet. Es sind kleine Maschinen, aber es ist unsere Welt.
Ich meine, es hängt auch so viel Wissen und Erkenntnisse an diesen Geräten manchmal dran.
Wir dürfen diese Geräte auch nicht zu wichtig machen. Aber für uns sind sie auch sehr wichtig. Sie sind teuer, sie sind natürlich auch sehr nützlich. Aber zum Beispiel gibt es keine Menschen an Bord. Ich glaube, es gibt Leute, die eine ähnliche Arbeit wie wir haben, aber da haben die Menschen unter ihren Händen.
Ich glaube, keine Menschen sterben. Aber wenn ich an die Wissenschaftler denke, die unter Umständen ihr Lebenswerk einbüßen, das ist schon ein bisschen... Jetzt sind wir eigentlich schon durch. Vielleicht zum Schluss noch mal kurz auf den Solar Orbiter zurück. 2017 geht es los. Wie lange wird das Gerät unterwegs sein?
Wir hoffen zuerst diese erste Phase, wo wir schon Wissenschaft machen, aber es ist die Reise dahin. Das dauert drei bis vier Jahre, abhängig von der Umlaufbahn, die wir wählen werden. Und dann planen wir auch ungefähr dreieinhalb Jahre Basis-Wissenschaft-Mission, mit einer möglichen Verlängerung von noch zwei oder drei Jahren und dann vielleicht weitere. Also sagen wir die Hälfte unterwegs, die elfte Wissenschaft, also Remote-Sensing-Wissenschaft, und dann eine Verlängerung weiter. Das ist eine gute und lange Mission. Das wird bis in den mitten der nächsten Jahrzehnten noch sehr gut funktionieren.
Ja, also wir müssen noch ein bisschen warten. Aber dann gibt es mit der aktuellen Kameratechnologie bestimmt sehr atemberaubende Fotografie und sonstige Analyse der Sonne. Ja, Paulo, ich sage mal vielen Dank. Bitte schön. Das war ein schöner Einstieg hier in die Mission Solar Orbiter. In ein paar Jahren geht es los, wenn denn alles klappt. Was wir natürlich hoffen und erwarten.
Es wird klappen.
Es wird klappen, ja. Ich bin überzeugt, dass zumindest wenn Probleme sich in den Weg stellen, dass es hier genug Leute gibt, die Tag und Nacht daran arbeiten werden, es zum Laufen zu bringen.
Mit Begeisterung.
Gut, das war es hier, Raumzeit 52. Vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören. Tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.